We've already talked a little bit about Cohen's d named after the statistician
Jacob Cohen. Cohen's d is an effect size measure, which gives us the
standardized mean difference. let's break this apart. We already know what it a
mean difference is. Mean difference is simply the difference between two means.
For example, between X bar and mu, as in the one-sample z-test and the
one-sample t-test. The word standardized, you may recall from our discussion of
z-scores. Remember, when we called z-scores standardized scores, what that
meant was we were taking a difference between a raw score and the mean, and
dividing by the standard deviation. Cohen's d does something very similar. It
takes a difference in this case, in the one sample case between X bar and Mu
and it divides by the standard deviation of the sample. So, it's called the
standardized mean difference because we have a mean difference and then it's
turned into standard deviation unit. So, the interpretation of Cohen's d is how
far apart these means are in standard deviation units.